[Music]
Brun
Stevens so let's be honest being able to
do a dive roll is a pretty cool thing
and there's a reason why we see
characters doing these in a large
proportion of video games and movies but
a dive roll is a progression that builds
upon the basic breakfall and learning to
breakfall is a skill that everyone can
benefit from you don't have to be able
to do some flamboyant dive roll unless
you want to but just knowing
instinctually how to fall correctly can
save you from some unnecessary injuries
and there's also the performance aspect
which is why I initially learned how to
do it and so I'm going to cover that
side of things as well for the
performance guys watching this
video so welcome today guys my name is
Grant Stevens and in this video I'm
going to be talking about the benefits
of learning to break fall correctly and
I'm also going to be providing a
practical tutorial on the movement and
then progressing into more difficult
variations like d roles and before we
get into the rest of the video you can
head to my channel which is youtube.com/
Stevens my channel is mainly focused
upon martial arts training Fitness and
personal development so for the first
part let's talk about some of the
benefits of just having a basic
understanding of how to break fall
correctly now it is something that's
essential in many martial arts Styles
but even just for people that don't
train in martial arts having an
understanding of this can go a long way
towards injury prevention especially in
terms of been able to protect vulnerable
areas of the body like the head spine
and the joints and I'm sure you've seen
accident clips like this online but I
always think a lot of this stuff could
be subverted if people just learned how
to fall safely but in order to be able
to do that it needs to become something
that's instinctual and kind of your
natural reaction to Falling which you
can only get through a lot of training
because a lot of people in these clips
seem to assume a really similar shape
where they just playay out and the
natural reaction for them seems to be to
actually stare at the ground as they
approach it but you know it doesn't have
to be something really extreme like this
either many people fall and break their
arms and stuff like that because their
instinct is to just put their hands down
and when you're traveling at enough
speed towards the ground your limbs are
just going to buckle and can't take that
pressure and the goal with this will be
to get to a level of naturalness to
where your first reaction to stumbling
or falling off balance will be to roll
out and do a brake fall and that's
because you subconsciously know you're
falling or approaching the ground at too
great a speed to just put your hands
down and this is something that happened
to me personally quite recently actually
I was riding my bike at quite a high
speed and the chain for some reason
snapped and went into the front wheel
sort of stopping the bike instantly and
sending me flying over the handlebars
but my reaction to roll out was so
instinctual that I didn't even realize
it had happened until afterwards and I
was already back on my feet and I was in
the middle of a road as well at the time
this happened so it could have really
been much worse on the performance side
it carries loads of benefits in terms of
skill development and will help other
movement abilities incidentally with
things like overall body awareness
coordination and something that might
not be so obvious is an improvement in
your reflexes specifically touching on
what I said earlier with reacting and
falling much more safely to unexpected
trips and falls and I know this isn't
something that's likely to happen often
for a lot of people especially if you're
somebody that's young and have good
stability and balance B and stuff but
I'm sure you'll be able to recall in
your own life there are those incidents
that are out of your control like the
one with me on my bike in which this
happens and so it's always just a good
skill to know so I personally learned
how to do a dive roll when I was a kid
and it was before I'd done any martial
arts training actually it was just from
seeing things in movies and like video
games and stuff and I just thought it
was a cool skill to learn and I'd say
that's the best way to go about training
something like this is just to go out of
your own curiosity and start trying
things out in a way that's fun and
enjoyable but I noticed when I got a
little bit older that this skill also
transferred really well into other
things I was into like tricking
especially in terms of developing that
overall body awareness and control and
you know just making everything a little
bit safer and it just gives you a little
bit more confidence when attempting some
higher level moves because inevitably a
part of tricking is that you're going to
crash and fall so having that knowledge
that you can fall safely is just going
to give you that extra bit of
reassurance so those were just some of
the benefits of learning how to break
fall and dive roll but now we're going
to move on to the Practical section and
I'm going to be starting with a basic
breakfall tutorial and building up into
progressions of different variations of
dive rolls
and there's something else that might
help with your brake Falls and general
agility barefoot shoes so barefoot shoes
also sometimes called a minimal Footwear
are shoes essentially designed to more
closely mimic the way that you use your
feet when you're not wearing shoes which
is of course how feet evolved to be used
so to this end they have a much thinner
Soul so you can actually feel the ground
underneath your feet they also come with
no heel there's no heel to toe drop this
not only forces you to use your body's
full range of motion you're not keeping
your feet locked in that state of plti
flection but it also means that when you
do push off your feet off the ground you
can do so more powerfully because you
have more room to move you have a wider
toe block so your toes can spay out and
balance and all these things help you
with this kind of agility with rolls
with balancing with climbing all those
things and that's why I personally
couldn't go back to regular Footwear now
having go barefoot make in my opinion
the very best barefoot shoes and the
great thing is there have such a wide
variety for all different kinds of
occasions whether you want to wear smart
foot wear whether you want to go hiking
whether you're going to the gym they're
extremely comfortable highly durable and
they're ethically sourced so I highly
recommend giving them a try and by their
viewers can get 15% off their order by
going to Vivo barefoot.com and then
entering code the bioner 15 thanks again
to Vivo bearfoot for sponsoring this
video and now back over to Grant so now
we're going to move on to the tutorial
section and the first thing we're going
to learn is the most basic level of
breakfall which is really simple start
on one knee and place down the hand onto
the ground of the same arm so if your
left knee is down with your right leg in
in front then your left hand should be
the one that's placed onto the ground
then we use the opposite hand to guide
us into the rolling motion and we do
that downwards at this angle and then
literally all you do is push off the
legs to initiate the movement using that
hand to guide you over and when you do
this make sure that you're tucking in
the head and legs in order to keep the
momentum going joing the roll and you
want to try and finish in a similar
position to which you
started the next progression is to do
this from a steady walk and the
important thing is to try to make the
movement fluid so you're not having to
kill the momentum before doing the brake
fall rather you're flowing with it and
if you've done that well then you should
be able to walk straight off like I do
here when you've gotten used to this I
recommend doing something like this
drill where you just perform repeated
brake Falls going side to side without
resetting too much during each one and
this is one of the ways that you can
make this a natural reaction is just by
repeating it quickly and Brake fallen in
awkward and suboptimal starting
positions next is a slight variation in
which I'm brake falling from a side on
position and you might notice here at
this angle it's not actually necessary
for me to place down a hand and instead
I drop down onto my tricep and shoulder
to guide me into the
roll and you can also do this walking
backwards as well as you can see here
for another variation and although it
doesn't look the cleanest it's better
than slamming onto your
back so now we're going to move on to
the actual dive roll and I recommend
building up to the full thing how I am
doing here so firstly doing like a mini
dive roll from a static position where
you have really small amount of air time
and doing this from static is actually
more difficult than from moving so it's
a it's a good way to make sure you're
really comfortable with that roll
technique before building
up next just like how we built
progression in the basic brake fall
we're going to walk into a mini dive
roll to build confidence again make sure
you're carrying that momentum from the
walk into the roll in a fluid motion
then what we do is literally just build
up the speed at which we approach the
roll until we can do the full version
from a short run once you're good at
this you can begin to make the dive more
aggressive which you can do by running
faster into it and jumping higher but to
do this it's important to lift the hands
and legs upwards as you jump into to it
like this so as you can see here as I
jump there's that little push upwards
which gives me more height now I hadn't
really done any of these a long time
before shooting this video so I can see
here that my technique isn't the
cleanest and I probably overdo the
lifting of the leg but you can see here
how it creates this nice Arc of movement
that the body follows as the legs meet
each other in the air and lastly it's
really important to tuck your legs in
tightly when you're rolling in otherwise
you're going to come out heavy and slam
down again think of a fluid motion
throughout the whole movement I admit on
some of these I'm not optimally tucked
in at the end and I'm coming down a
little heavy and this actually hurt
quite a bit because the ground was solid
from the frosts so heed the warning a
further variation which is actually the
way I prefer to do it is to come down
straight and roll over the head and I
find this actually produces a cleaner
dive roll when you do this you place
both hands down on the ground so you
don't come down heavy as you're going to
roll straight over the head and spine so
I wouldn't do this unless you're already
quite comfortable with the other version
as it's technically more dangerous and
you can build up to this in the same way
as the others a further variation is you
can perform the dive roll from 2 feet
and this is a good version to do if
you're diving through some like in this
clip because you haven't got that space
for the legs to be out of alignment and
you can notice in these clips that I'm
also doing the straight over the head
variation as it feels more natural for
me from the two-footed jump next you can
begin to dive roll over obstacles and I
recommend starting with something small
and ideally padded so you don't get
injured and then build up confidence to
higher obstacles there'll likely be a
mental block with this that you have to
overcome as well and even if you know
you're diving way higher than the
obstacle Sometimes When approaching it
you might freeze or hesitate so just be
careful and build up slowly and finally
for a bit of showing off if you get
really comfortable with all of the other
variations you can do a running front
flip it's not a dive roll progression
but has the same general components and
is actually a lot easier than it looks
when you're traveling at enough speed
all right guys I hope you enjoyed that
one as I touched on at the beginning of
the video this is something that you
need to do a lot of repetitions for to
make it habitual and your natural
reaction if you fall off balance or
something like that so a way to do this
in regular sessions to get those reps in
is just to start using brake Falls as
part of your warmup you often see
wrestlers do this when they warm up
they'll do laps of doing forward roles
and other gymnastics skills in order to
warm up for their main practice again
please head to my channel youtube.com/
Grant Stevens Ma and subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video
guys